dr. taryn Narula is here with us to
answer your most pressing questions on
the corona virus at our good morning
good morning yes folks it is to give us
their their their urgent most urgent
questions good really good and the first
one is one actually I had to which is
from a viewer on Instagram who asked
what scares me is getting help if I'm
really sick when do I know it's an
emergency and this is the important
thing to know so for most people it's
going to be mild the symptoms are to be
mild you'll recover but you do need to
understand when it progresses and those
things to look for would be shortness of
breath chest pain a change in your
mental status you're more confused more
lethargic bluish coloration to your
fingers or your lips these things should
prompt you or someone who's maybe with
you to say something is getting worse
and you need to seek medical attention
now if you do choose to go to the
emergency room you might want to try to
call ahead again to warn them that
you're coming so they can prepare and
decrease the risk of exposure I love
that question to anything because I
thought you I get a runny nose is that
it I know my chest is that it the
slightest little thing you're now
wondering is that it right and go past
that is that it part right well
certainly some people do have mild
symptoms but what you really want to be
aware of are those warning signs I like
this one to Rachel in Colorado I also
was wondering about this can you recover
and then relapse this is so interesting
and there have been some reports out of
Asia saying that people got the
infection and then a couple of weeks
later they got it again so what we know
about most viruses is that when you get
an infection your body mounts a reaction
you produce antibodies those antibodies
do provide you protection if you see
that virus again the big question is
really how long do you are you immune
for is it a year is it a lifetime is the
virus going to change a little bit like
the flu does so that you need for
example a vaccine every year the one
caveat to this is that there are some
people who don't produce as big an
immune reaction so they may in fact be
able to kind of get infected again if
you don't have symptoms anymore but you
think you had it or you did have it
are you still contagious another really
great question so you know what we know
is that if you get exposed usually you
will mount symptoms within those 2 to 14
days that's why that quarantine period
is 14 days if you do test
positive for kovat and you're told to
kind of isolate then when can you
re-emerge and that's really when you've
been free of fever for 72 hours without
fever reducing medications your symptoms
are improving and it's been seven days
since you first had that symptom or you
have two negative tests all right we
have a Keith from Montana had a question
about those who are potentially
high-risk here's what is let's let's
listen we keep hearing how older
Americans are the most affected by the
corona virus but also those with
underlying conditions my question is is
keeping we get more detail on those
underlying conditions for me
specifically I have a type 1 diabetic
child thank you so it's important to
recognize what some of these underlying
conditions are so hypertension
cardiovascular disease chronic lung
disease including things like asthma
diabetes kidney disease and individuals
who are on dialysis cirrhosis sickle
cell anemia cancer and anyone who's
immunosuppressed so they take
medications or they have a condition
where their immune system is weaker
these are kind of the big categories
that you need to know about yeah and I
like the question about older Americans
because I want to know what that means I
went to the grocery store to get orange
juice yesterday walked in walked out my
kids just hammered me because they said
you're over 60 ok thinking can I not go
to can people over 60 who are in good
health not go the grocery store is that
not a good idea well I mean again the
more you can distance yourself so if
you're going in an off time where
there's nobody in the grocery store
that's probably fine but the more you
can stay home and keep that distance
important all right yes going home to my
computer that's fun thank you very much
we appreciate it terribly back in our
next hour to answer more of your
questions including the difference
between allergies and the corona virus
the symptoms can seem like they're the
same and as our pandemic reshapes daily
life in America please continue sending
us your questions you can email
coronavirus at CBS news.com we will take
a look